[Music]
we are celebrating the one year
anniversary of meow wolf's omega mart
here inside area 15 and i've heard a
million and seven people have been
inside to check it out so come on let's
go see what the hype's all about
[Music]
well this is a fun way to grocery shop
here at omegamart inside area 15 but
there's so much more to do than just
shop congratulations it's been a year
joseph let's talk about it what do
people experience the minute they walk
in the doors here confusion
confusion and delight that is what our
guests experience when they walk into a
mega mart this is the world's most
exceptional grocery store it is unlike
any other store there are things on the
shelves that you can purchase if you can
pick it up off the shelf it is for
purchase although it may not look like
it's an actual item for purchase it is
it is actually kind of like a playground
and it's an adult playground and
everyone gets to explore and play adults
forget how to play and so we at meow
wolf like to give you that opportunity
to do that again well joseph i'm ready
to play let's go do some exploring okay
so it's all about mystery and
discovering things on your own so i'm
actually gonna invite you to open this
door right here all right you're taking
us through the secret janitor doorway
let's go
[Music]
this is overwhelming in the best way
let's talk about how long did it take to
build this and run me through the
process you were here from the beginning
i have been here for quite a while yes
so it this is about a mega mart is about
250 individual art projects
installations and contributions from
over
325 different artists and contributors
not only from las vegas but also from
across the globe
it took over three years to conceive and
build this exhibit it's so incredible
and we came through a janitor's door is
everyone free to roam around and explore
anywhere and everywhere yes omegamart is
designed as a choose your own adventure
there is no set path there's no one way
through the exhibit as you've
experienced people pop out of corners
and little walkways you didn't even know
existed and suddenly they're right next
to you so yeah to choose your own
adventure that everyone gets to play
okay joseph we found the robot i hear
there are multiple robots here let's
talk about this room and what you can do
in here so we are standing in the dram
core offices so from a story point this
is the corporate offices that owns
omegamart so here you can actually dive
into our story these are all computer
terminals that belong to each of the
characters of our story you can actually
touch the computers read their computer
files look at their emails you can open
their desk drawers and actually see
personal items that belong to them so
you can really dive into the story
that's what makes this exhibit different
than the rest of las vegas you know it's
not just a show where you sit in the
audience and passively watch the show
you get to be part of the show here
you're immersed in the world and it's
not only stuff you get to touch but
there are employees that are omega mart
and male wolf employees that you get to
talk to and you get to have a fully
immersive experience with them well
that's a wrap here at omegamart happy
one year anniversary i'm gonna go finish
my grocery shopping now